[Applause]
oh trump
trying to get that vote yeah yeah yeah
hey bro
people be lying uh-huh
find some votes
what is the controversy here real talk
what are they
yeah he's just doing the same [ __ ] he's
been doing on twitter this whole time
yeah yo this election was stolen find
these votes they stole the election
that's all he's saying everybody's
acting like this is some smoking gun or
something
but it is wrong though is it not wrong
yeah the facts the the
feeling no facts like the fact side is
like people are saying he's attempting
to stage a coup by forcing
the officials in georgia to try to he's
not forcing he's he's happening
yo fam i'm the president find some votes
yeah do what you do
find them vote the feelings part of it
is that's just lit you got to do what
you got to do
i don't know about that i love how he
talks though like he talks on the phone
knowing that he's being recorded yeah
like that would be great if you would go
find them yeah we just need one more
yeah it's like i heard i heard i heard
they're there
i heard they got ripped up you just
gotta you know but that's to say
in the same way mafia meant to get off
charges a lot
that's how i feel like he's gonna be
with this like all right you know what
he's trying to do i guess but he never
says anything that you can pin him down
with you're not gonna get charged for
nothing it's bad for the country
yeah the move is i like the move he's
out of here
and the move is yo behave yourself i
think the powers of b are going to come
and just go yo behave yourself
and go yo listen here [ __ ]
yo you're not supposed to [ __ ] up what
we got going on somehow you did it
yeah they're literally like i don't know
how the [ __ ] you did it somehow you did
it
yeah you tricked the system it ain't
supposed to work like this okay but you
tricked the system and you somehow beat
the system for four years
we got it back to where it's supposed to
be you're not going to jail as long as
you keep your mouth shut
and i think that's gonna be a deal and
if he opens his mouth you're gonna see
them taxes come out you're gonna see a
lot of problems if he keeps his mouth
quiet you're gonna see him chilling
on a boat somewhere enjoying his real
estate business and doing what the [ __ ]
he does
yeah that's my assumption but he's even
like galvanizing some senators to reject
the [ __ ] election results yeah that's
the [ __ ] that
is anybody even paying that any mind
like you know biden's gonna be president
i think ted cruz is
yeah that guy's a [ __ ] yeah dude that
guy is a
super cup him and marco rubio are
embarrassing
the biggest
destroyed his [ __ ] wife his wife he
salted the [ __ ] out of his wife and that
you know how big a [ __ ] he is this is
how big a cuck is
trump is [ __ ] his wife and pulls his
dick out and then starts
about to calm on his wife and then he
just swan dives
in front of the [ __ ] and gobbles that
[ __ ] up that's the type of cucks
that ted cruz is a super [ __ ]
unbelievable levels of [ __ ] dude
imagine someone insulted your wife bro
publicly she's
ugly she's not the prettiest but you
don't gotta say it
right you don't gotta say it you just
let that [ __ ] be bygones yes
yeah what's a bygone bro
is that really what it is it's bygone
all these stupid ass sayings
we gotta get them to feel like when you
kick out your gay son i think by god
by god go away
i'm a man of god you are not
okay um so what are we thinking about
this that's just classic trump you know
it's not surprising obviously he's
trying to do whatever he can to stay in
power
but uh right whoever i recorded it
he could sue them maybe i don't think so
i mean if you know you got to find out
who recorded it or like or
you know who leaked it but i imagine
every presidential phone call is
recorded yeah
the phone got to be tapped to the
president yeah yeah anyway it's just
it's just one of these tricky things
like i think people are latching on to
it because
this is a perfect example what this is
the media needs trump
you know i mean like we already know
he's out we know there's not going to be
an electoral college nonsense we already
know what's going on
yeah but the media needs this big boogie
man to talk about and trump is that
boogeyman
and so any story that has him
connected in it where he looks like an
idiot or he looks potentially evil
they're corrupt
particularly corrupt yes because it's
already over
it's like the finals are done you're
going to leak a story about
lebron after it's done no yeah well not
lebron i guess in the case it's
complaining about it's like when the
kings lost to the lakers in that one and
what two thousand two
yeah you're still like y'all the
officials the officials all right
who cares yeah it's over it's nice
it's over it's over like what what do
they really want what do we want to
happen here
you want to see trump hung is that it
like the people who are saying this is
treasonous like do you want is that what
you want you want to see the president
get home
is that is that what's happening no i
don't know i own squad like what do
y'all want like
him go to jail for what with tax fraud
and everything else yo yo first of all i
paid
i saw the amount of i'm supposed to pay
in taxes defraud them man
defraud them you know this [ __ ] is
preposterous the fraud
anybody who defrauds the government for
their taxes is my hero
yeah my hero and i'll say it on the
podcast they probably listening right
now
i'ma figure it out painting the papers
here we
come bro i don't know i don't know if
you will
figure it out this is the clip they're
gonna take andrew schultz
tax evasion i would figure it out i
support it
administration yeah there we go there we
go there we go
this taxes are crazy bro why are you
[ __ ] paying them
sorry i just got hated thank you
taxation of representation especially
for black people we shouldn't be paying
them at all
i shouldn't be paid either yes i'm not
racist
that's my favorite just be racist pay
them yes yo what if what if only
what if only people
yeah this is dangerous yeah yeah i was
about to be on board already before you
even said
who should be paying taxes mostly whites
that's not true
white people need to not only specific
types
yes specific types specifically not me
question wait a question would all of
you in this room besides taylor
be upset if reparations were given by
just
not for just black people not having to
pay taxes like
that honestly honestly i would be more
upset
really i'll be i'd rather one time
because it's nice paid out
printed up the money oh but then that's
your tax dollars going to
us i'm fine with you so that's like you
taking some responsibility to me and
dove in the hotel
uh-huh i thought it would be worse that
way
it's coming out they would raise our
taxes let me tell you something i i've
said this on this podcast before
[ __ ] you could up to i think
it's wrong to do over 40
in tax but anything over 50 percent if
you're paying in taxes
you work for the government you are an
employee of the government nobody who
pays 50
some people didn't figure it out in time
let me tell you something
people pay over 50
that's the way it's set up right this is
corona we lost money
so why do you think how do we lose money
we lost how do we lose money
right we make the money yes we had a bad
year this was a bad bad year
you just got here
they're going to jail i'm out here being
honest out here paying over 50 percent
of taxes
y'all all going to prison mark 50
percent of your total income which is
more than 50 percent
son do you're wild i took a hit
we couldn't go on the road like it's
this guy going to prison
this guy's going to prison this guy
going to prison
let me tell you it's going to be you and
donald trump sitting in that [ __ ]
jail cell dude
me out here paying my [ __ ] whatever
it is over 50 percent of taxes
over 50 percent of taxes bro i work for
the government
i work from january to june for free
which i was working every day for free
and the government just took all that
money what the [ __ ] they did
what did they do i rode my bicycle here
i didn't even take a subway
i should get all my money back yep at
least we should get jackets
i never called 911 jackets we're us
government employees
yo can i get a jacket bro a little pen
a lapel i know what you're talking about
with jackie i thought it was something i
promised to buy them but i never got
them